because I feel like there are men out
there that okay there are men out there
that don't care about the size and there
are men out there that specifically
going for bigger goals I remember that
they even are feeders they purposely
okay
like fat women I get it obviously being
fat is not so in society I mean just
being attractive but however I don't
think it's fair to say what what percent
of guys I don't know statistics no I'm
saying like come on let's just be like
let's just be real for a second yeah
is that common men to be like this is
what girls always do it's every time we
make a point that's for the man and that
makes sense we have to bring up the
exception if if that was the case then
you would see the men with the most
options the most handsome men and the
most rich men with fat chicks but
they're not